hey guys have you ever wondered why some
guys have really clean and clear skin
and some guys just struggle a little bit
well I believe it's got a lot to do with
your skincare routine so I'm gonna give
you my male model skincare routine with
the best tips and we're starting right
now
[Music]
hey welcome to D LM model lifestyle I am
Daniel and if you're new to my channel
please subscribe so that you won't miss
anything new and just so you know I have
not been sponsored to do this video by
any company I'm just doing this video
because it is a request from my
subscribers so this is for you guys
alright now I have 4 basic steps in my
skincare routine and I'm gonna share
that with you with a couple of tips as
well and the first step is to wash your
face two times a day with a good water
soluble cleanser instead of bars of soap
why because the ingredients they use to
keep those soap in that bar form is
actually the culprits that clog your
pores so you gotta wash your face two
times a day and if you work out a lot
please wash your face after every
workout as well and I just say you know
if you want to check out any of the
products that I'm gonna talk about in
this video then I've made it easier for
you and I've added it in the video
description down below so you can go and
check those out and do a little bit of
research now I like the face wash from
PC for men which is a really good
product
[Music]
now I'm gonna give you three tips that's
very important to know when you wash
your face and a lot of people don't know
this actually the first step is to wash
your face with lukewarm water yes we all
know the rule that you have to wash your
face first with hot water so that opens
up those pores and then you rinse it
with cold water so it closes it up turns
out it's not true yeah it's a myth
now exposing your face to different kind
of extremes actually causes you to have
dryness skin irritations and blood
vessel ruptures so just wash your face
with lukewarm water just to keep it
happy tip number two when you wash your
face and don't go crazy don't over wash
it why because it will just lead to
dryness irritation and even inflammation
all which destroys your faces ability to
fight those pimple causing bacteria that
nobody likes my third tip in washing
your face is gently pat your face dry
rubbing it roughly to dry it instead of
just patting it gently will destroy your
skin's elasticity ilist us a list Isis
anyway you get what I'm saying
it can result in major skin sagging in
the future and you don't want that okay
now let's go back to the skincare
routine my second step is shaving
normally I don't really like to shave
but some clients want me to really shave
for the job so then I have to do it no
choice but there's a few things that you
need to know about shaving I will shave
my beard right after I washed my face or
after I took the shower because then my
beauty softer and I also get a cleaner
shaving I shave up a thin layer of
fragrance-free PC for men leave my skin
looking fresh and not aggravated or
irritated alright so when I'm done
shaving I usually move on to step number
three which is applying PC for men
soothe and
but right now I'm all out and I cannot
get any more of it because I'm in South
Korea and somehow South Korea do not
allow this product into their country
just like they don't allow other
products like the resist nine vh9 from
polos choice and this is an amazing
product for those enlarged pores or any
other kind of imperfections anyway so
instead of using the soothe and smooth I
use the clarifying lotion from Clinique
which is not bad just use a cotton pad
and apply it just gently on your face
the clarifying lotion will clear any
clogged pores it diminishes the look of
wrinkles and it improves your skin
texture and it's great to remove these
dead skin cells and refines pores to
have a clearer complexion
step number four is using a really good
moisturizer if it's in the morning I use
the daytime protect
SPF 30 from PC for men and I use it
every day this is a great moisturizer
that not only improves my skin but it
protects me from the Sun which means it
protects me from the aging the
moisturizer is not heavy it's not oily
and so if you put it on it's very light
and it doesn't look shiny at all which
is great and when it's nighttime I use
the PC for men
nighttime repair that helps and repair
my skin while I sleep alright guys that
is my male model skincare routine that
keeps my face looking fresh and just
clear and clean off pimples and acne and
everything that is bad now if you want
to go and check those products out
remember I've made it easier for you and
I've added the links here in the video
description down below so you can go and
check those out and do a little bit of
research now if you liked the video give
me a thumbs up subscribe here so you
won't miss any of my other videos and
that's it
yes thanks guys Cheers